e volevo di Hermione Vabbè
Porca [__] mi sono cagato addosso Una
cazzo ridi No ragazzi
Prova a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video Io sono Ah quello del
Giappone No quello là visto che avete
già visto il video del Nintendo Super
Nintendo World quale gli Universal
Studios C'è un'altra cosa cosa avete
intuito dal titolo e dalla copertina
visto che l'avete cliccata stiamo per
fare l'experience di Hogwarts che c'ha
gli Universal Studios di Osaka in
Giappone vediamo che cosa sono riusciti
a creare ma mi aspetto di tutto ragazzi
all'entrata è questa si passa dalla
foresta proibita va bene C'è una cosa
Comunque ragazzi che non mi piace salve
salve lui era proprio uguale a Grid
iniziano le varie reference tra cui la
macchina di Tom
vediamo subito il posto che fa la foto
Mi scusi Vabbè però mi si vede la
finestrino
Ciao ragazzi
Allora allora fa strano che questo sia
fatto in Giappone Nel senso sembra
proprio strano perché non è lo stile già
non c'entra una sega con lo stile
giapponese non avevo niente Però
effettivamente l'hanno riprodotto
fedelmente ragazzi è pazzesco ma
praticamente
è proprio identico ragazzi ce l'hanno
fatto l'hanno fatto uguale no no
vabbè Ecco Vabbè ragazzi Io già ho preso
le robe da Nintendo Super Nintendo World
non è che posso comprare tutto eh Ma
questa è riuscita ad entrare Mi sa che
questa era l'uscita sono entrato dalle
casse cioccorane
silente e tutti gli altri Madonna ma è
fatto benissimo ragazzi ovviamente le
caramelle tutti i gusti più uno glicemia
Avada Kedavra Scusi la stanza della
necessità ho notato adesso che tutta
questa gente qua e in fila partendo da
tipo qua e in fila per la burrobirra
cioè il manco se me la danno gratis non
è che odio la burrobirra Eh però non
vale 10 euro non si tutto manco a Milano
un apero il burro spritz non esiste e ci
avviciniamo all'attrazione principale e
invece della burrobirra c'è questa magia
era ragazzi è l'unica magia che conosco
attualmente altro che burrobirra e una
borraccia all'interno della quale
inserite acqua fine e sopra la borraccia
potete inserire un Pod un gusto
qualsiasi perché qualsiasi perché ce ne
sono un miliardo vuoi vedere veramente
mentre quello che volete ad esempio qua
c'è la Cherry Cola Basil Lemon yuzu
yuzu Rosemary ma il gusto la novità
dell'estate che batte tutti Secondo me è
il Virgin mojito c'è il gusto del Virgin
poi vabbè sentire il gusto del Virgin
mojito Ma che burro bio quello Aprite
girate fuori Il Pod e lo inseriamo
adeguatamente sopra la borraccia tirando
leggermente in alto Il Pod perché così
si attiva magicamente questa ma questa è
magia raga Questa è magia è una volta
versata l'acqua all'interno acqua
ragazzi perché alla fine non è una
bevanda di quelle e acqua e acqua
semplicemente che prende il sapore
dallolfatto quindi Il Pod che abbiamo
inserito È l'unico modo in cui io lo so
astemio quindi non si può fare
quindi è così che si sentono quelli che
bevono il Virgin mojito bene Si può
rimanere idratati con l'acqua che rimane
sempre fresca essendo termica quindi per
l'estate Questa è una manna dal cielo
Fatemi sapere ragazzi se lo provate vi
lascio qua sotto in descrizione il
codice Favij perché con il link sempre
qua sotto avete il 10% di sconto per due
settimane se lo provate Fatemi sapere
Intendo anche soprattutto il gusto
Virgin mojito perché attualmente uno dei
miei preferiti Ciao ciao gioca col
terapesca Ecco anche detto questo
torniamo alla nostra
[Musica]
ho spaccato tutto ragazzi è fatta
inspiegabilmente bene la cosa che mi fa
impazzire sono non è tanto il dettaglio
Ma la grandezza Cioè nel senso è proprio
grossa sembra veramente cioè io Hogwarts
non la immagino grossa Così è veramente
grossi dal video come sempre non si
percepisce una sega Scusate si muovono e
non so con che criterio perché sono
veramente
mi piace che hanno messo il doppiaggio
giapponese di Harry Potter
[Applauso]
Ma quando mai Silente già Stavolta
catenella
Eccoci qua ragazzi Eccoci qua tutto buio
hanno fatto Hogwarts al buio non è che
non è non è che i maghi non vedono
Oh che cazzo oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
cazzo mannaggia cazzo Ma che è successo
stavo volando Oh ma che cacchio sta
succedendo
muore de Morricone Ah ah ah oh mio Dio
com'è possibile oh Dio i draghi
azzè
non c'entra Oddio ho benedetto che Cacca
AH ragazzi oh
un attimo Madonna Raga ma neanche ma
neanche gli horror che fa se ci sono i
ragni mi incazzo Eh No ragazzi i ragni
no Eh porca [__] questo è vero
ragazzi no eh no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no ragazzi
Oddio
no vi prego No adesso no no no no no no
no no no no no no raga questo no non
scherzare A parte gli scherzi ragazzi No
Eh No ragazzi no basta ma non era Nino
noi ragni No a parte gli scherzi raga Eh
no basta No ragazzi No ragazzi no no no
non ce la posso fare
quando finisce oddio porca [__] mi
sono cagato addosso sul serio basta
adesso Ahia Basta voglio scendere Fatemi
scendere Basta
Oh minchia a Cristiano Ronaldo
attenzione pazzesche mi fate scendere
voglio scendere Vorrei scendere da
questa giostra mi avete rotto il cazzo
coi ragni Quindi voglio scendere Fatemi
scendere c'è un tornado Harry Potter fai
qualcosa Ma che cazzo ne so io ho visto
solo Attack on Titan Ahia Ah minchia di
Senatori Meno male Pensavo fosse un
ragno
Ah i serpenti vanno bene i serpenti
Vanno bene questi me li accollo i
soldati me li accolto Ok Oddio
[Musica]
Grazie Harry Potter ma vado a chiedere
anche a te
sì quello che dici tu in giapponese
Harry va bene
Cos'è che hai detto non lo so dove il
distretto di shingascino non lo so ma
questo non esci Cascina Questo è il Wall
Maria
ma quella non è mai la voce di Silente
regà Allora ragazzi che dire viene
vomitare vado a bere la burrobirra si
per digerire quello di prima visto che
era Easy andiamo a fare una cosa easy
fontane di Hogwarts Agua 20 e Funziona
fantastico sapevi tutta c'è un horc e
qui ti fanno salire su dei cestini da
picnic si chiama questa questa è
l'attrazione
dell'ippogrifo cosa c'ha di Ippogrifo
questa roba qua non l'ho capito però
Vabbè l'importante è che voliamo ma
[Musica]
Ah ho capito che cosa c'ha di Ippogrifo
la testa pesano le attrazioni tutto il
resto sono i negozi ovviamente però figo
Figo soprattutto gli Ippogrifo in vimini
questo è carino Eh ma io mi sono sempre
chiesto Ma stai bacchette ci sarà
davvero qua dentro e fake Beh aprirsi si
apre C'è veramente la bacchetta quindi è
vero e appena fuori troviamo il lago
proibito ma sto male raga sto male no
gli elicotteri non ci sono in Harry
Potter ci sono ma non nel mondo magico
ha senso ci hanno le scope usano quelle
ma fighissimo Ah la vendono vendono una
scopa costa quanto costa una scopa non
chiedo 4.500 Yen costa una scopa sono
tipo
Tutto a posto Ti piace la vuoi le
piaceva la scopa comunque 4.500 yen sono
tipo €30 di scopa finta parlando di
scope finte c'è anche questa che non ho
capito perché però questa costa €100
questa cosa costa 500 euro
Ah sono gli scacchi dei maghi Va bene mi
sembra un po' eccessivo però vabbè è
questo era il la parte dell'universo
Studios di Hogwarts molto carina molto
carina Mi dispiace che le prime riprese
sono stato un po' buie però purtroppo
all'interno della prima sala era tutto
totalmente da niente niente quale
proprio preciso spiccicato a quello che
c'ha Los Angeles L'hanno rifatto
identico merita tantissimo Comunque
merita tantissimo l'università studio
meritano Se passate da Osaka
assolutamente
mi incazzo Tranne i ragni i ragni fanno
cagare ma non qua in generale però
soprattutto qua perché erano grossi come
mia nonna Comunque sia Ragazzi io Luigi
e Mario non ce li vedo proprio a
Hogwarts Però fa niente Spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto e come al solito
ragazzi se vi è piaciuto lasciate un
commento e un mi piace ozgu
R Che vuol dire Draco Malfoy fa schifo